alright this winning $1,000,000
automatically make you happier professor
Laurie Santos explores what science
reveals about happiness and how our
brains adapt to it she created the most
popular class offered at Yale University
called psychology and the good life and
in her podcast the happiness lab she
interviews notable guests like figure
skater Michelle Kwan David Byrne from
the Talking Heads coach Bob Bowman and
veteran and actor JR Martinez Santos
talks to them about their quest to find
happiness and looks at the data behind
their decisions professor good morning
thanks for having me so you created the
most popular class ever at Yale
University did that make you happy it
came with a lot of logistical problems
that didn't make me so happy but it was
great
now this podcast is going to be a path
to happiness for the rest of us how so
that's right I mean the idea is not
everybody's gonna take a Yale class you
know everybody has the SATs to get into
Yale but everybody's focused on
happiness and so we wanted to make all
these insights available to everyone the
first ones was a lottery yeah because
everybody thinks if I could just win the
lottery if I could just do it it would
make me happy you highlight a guy who
won and then ended up taking his own
life because you think money and I only
hear rich people say this though money
doesn't make you happy but there is
research and science to back that up
that's right so researchers have been
looking at this right trying to figure
out at what point in your salary do you
kind of hit the point that more money
won't make you happy and so two Nobel
prize-winning economists looked at this
they kind of measured a bunch of
different measures of well-being so how
stress people feel how much positive
emotion people had and they plotted that
across your salary and what they find is
that at low incomes yeah more money
makes you happy if you jump from ten
thousand dollars in the u.s. to 20
you're gonna be less stressed if you say
people that make thirty think if they
make fifty they'll be okay that's right
make a hundred think if they make 250
they'll be okay and but the real number
is what they found the real number seems
to be around 75 K like in all these
measures you just kind of level off
which is really surprising to most
people so what a billionaires want even
more money well I think we make the
generalization you know when we don't
have that much money when you make more
you're like oh all of a sudden it feels
good and then when you're rich you're
like I'm still not happy and you're like
ah it just must not be enough why is it
75 though I thought
was an interesting number not even a
hundred what the empirical data bear out
but a frustrating thing is it's like
just 10,000 above the median income in
the US so another interesting finding is
Olympic medalists if their third - away
from first they're happier actually
long-term than the second-place finisher
why I think the second place finisher
has a salient comparison that makes them
feel bad they almost got gold you know
there are 0.2 seconds away where's the
bronze medalist is like I almost wasn't
even up here it was lost I feel great
you say our minds lie to us when it
comes to happiness what do you mean I
mean we have all these strong intuitions
about what will make us happier more
money that'll make me happy you know
getting a promotion that'll make me
happy but then you look at people who
get that and they're not happy yeah
the podcast touches on what you call the
psychological immune system what is that
exactly that's one of the reasons that
we're just more resilient than we think
you know when bad things happen someone
breaks up for you all of a sudden they
weren't good enough for me you know you
lose some money in the lottery like God
you know I didn't need it anyway this
immune system makes us feel good even
when bad things happen we just don't
realize we have it so how do we be
happier
professor Santos well stop focusing on
the things that don't matter money
accolades and so on and start focusing
on the things that do make time for
social connection take time to just be
present experience gratitude those are
the things that really matter you say we
even waiting in line can be a happy
experience yeah it's another you lost me
on that yeah
7,000 hours of our life spent yeah yeah
yeah well it's an opportunity cost
because we could be spending that time
better sometimes we're kind of scrolling
or Instagram you not feeling good but we
could talk to the person next to us it
turns out that they want to talk to us
Lori the research suggests they do this
is a researcher Nick Eppley who looked
at this and he tested afterwards does
the person you're talking to feel better
and he finds that in fact they do that's
interesting what happens what about when
things don't go according to plan
this is another case where I think we
forecast that everything's going to be
terrible but in practice that
psychological immune system you
mentioned it kicks in and it makes us
feel better better than we expect and
that means that things aren't gonna our
circumstances aren't gonna affect us as
much as we often think if you see Lori
in line somewhere say hello strike up a
conversation all right Lori sent us
thanks so much for being with us the
happiness lab
Cass is out today